did you see [ __ ] army hammer how he
let his kids suck his toe and everyone
went nuts thought it was Armageddon dude
I don't care it doesn't matter I
couldn't believe it
is it by the way is it like do people
think that like suck it on a toe is a
sexual thing I it was that what it was
it was like four seconds the kid was
just sucking on army hammers tell he's
he his own kid and he was like he's been
doing this for like an hour obviously
joking and the internet flipped out dude
his name was trending over 6,000 times
you know what I did I followed him I'm
[ __ ] Instagram cuz that's what you get
you get a follow dude that shit's funny
as hell what is it cuz it's a sexual
thing dude if my kid sucks my toe I go
what the [ __ ] are you doing and I film
it that's what I do I'm team army hammer
bro so I followed him on Instagram
because that's what you get when you're
a [ __ ] pro on Instagram he's a pro on
Instagram filming some [ __ ] and daily
life that people want to see people like
oh no I'm so bummed I looked at it it's
so gross no it's not dude AB although I
think that here's the thing if you think
it's gross you think of feet as a sexual
thing cuz why is it gross who cares
what if the kid was sucking on his
finger what's the difference it doesn't
matter it's [ __ ] toast dude and I got
a buddy who's that got like a foot
fetish like a serious one and that's
weird as [ __ ] he's a big comedian and he
loves feet and I would never tell you
who that is cuz I'm cuz I'm loyal but it
I'll tell you why it's not one of those
stories that ends with and that man is
me it's not me I don't get it and then
also some people are like ill feet like
go [ __ ] yourself look down you got him
but this guy loves feet you ever seen
like feet jobs on the internet like you
ever watch more than two seconds of it
you know how hard it is it's harder to
rent the [ __ ] car
you're like or it's harder than renting
a car
you let they're like like this you know
don't use anything to jerk anything off
unless it's got a thumb with it [ __ ]
knees all out and shits I'm not sexy
girlf York and you off with feet Hey
yeah if you can't use one then it
doesn't work you know you got to use
both because you don't have thumbs
that's weird
although I would like to be an effete
though it would be cool to be into feet
sexually because then you could be like
oh I got another thing that's like
people like I wish I was in the feet
it's weird but like I wish I had more
things I was into sexually I got pretty
much regular [ __ ] like I like to be kind
of dominant but then also that's pretty
much it you do three positions I've been
over this dude you do missionary you do
doggy style and then you do the girl on
top but you don't do also if you're a
guy on guy I'm you know I've never done
guy on guy I'm not gay but like if I
kind of wish I was so I could make those
rules too because if I make those rules
as a straight man people gonna get mad
but here's the rules anyway
okay get mad if you want you only do
doggy that's it you don't do it you
don't face each other until I was about
thirty I didn't think about like I
thought like oh you just do regular you
just do doggy gay guys just do doggy but
I was like you don't have to let go [ __ ]
you could do like face to face but then
it but then you're having sex with the
guy and the other guys the other guy's
looking at you it unplugged and then the
other guys it's okay it unplugged that
thing and then the other guys looking at
you but then he but then his his dick is
flopping all around you know I didn't
think about the other guy's dick when
you're having sex it's okay it just went
a little quieter that's all what
am i keeping going yeah I can hear
myself I never thought about the other
guy's dick in gay sex do you know I'm
saying you have a home for your penis if
you're the giver but the other guy's
penis is kind of more like like he's
looking for a gate at the airport
I'm saying you've never thought about
that if you're a straight dude you don't
really think about this stuff but I do
cuz you have to I think I have to think
about all the things to make all the
rules
the other guy's dick is looking for a
gate at the airport that's what he's
doing and then if he's his turn to give
he's like up found we're boarding and
the other guys like I've arrived at my
destination I wish I was into all this
stuff I wish I was gay I wish I was well
as long as it's legal you're not I'm
talking about the more the better dude
the more busting the better right that's
how it is